guarda quanto spazio c'è trustee due
alberi lo vedete lo spazio c'è lo spazio
perché non ci passa papa culo che
morisse il cugino di diarrea spruzzo dal
naso costruita in mezzo all'albero
sarebbe ma salve a tutti i ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video molto
molto molto divertente molto divertente
ragazzi perché non so se vi ricordate
visto gioco del cazzo che si chiama
giorno mi mancava uno mancava chica che
sarebbe cresta bella gnocca semente
ragazzi manca solo lei per concludere il
cerchio di tutta sto ben di dio di gente
tutta contenta di farmi il culo proviamo
a fare con chick a qualcosa di bello ci
carpacci piano è perché se noi giocarsi
come l'hanno fatta per ultima foreste i
mac cic ha nella foresta l'epo con mezza
foresta non sono nati in casa con circa
collezione dieci disegni che case lander
ma dai mass renderman posizione di
uscita bene primo e [ __ ] prendilo
non lo prende ok perfetto per farcela
ragazzi in totale o circa 300 secondi
adesso ne ho ancora 265 che per gli
altri ragazzo li che ho incontrato le
prime volte tantissimo per circa credo
di no
chi è che si è messo a disegnare
staccato di me lo spiegate otto disegni
rimanenti ragazzi non so se ci riuscirò
e non c'è ma è bellissimo mi sembra
davvero di rigiocare as renderman dei
vecchi tempi e stupendo sento dei rumori
problemi che succede
da dover 9 serio c'è già un disegno
perfetto veloci veloci non perdiamo
tempo forza c'è un edificio nella
recinzione mica mi sembra un edificio
bello disegno più bello dell'altro
ragazzi ma quindi il mio allora fatemi
capire una roba se li mi vede posso
scappare o sono morto a prescindere
giuro ragazzi che madara quanto abbaglia
ecco la mano è un lampione mi chiami
sono pagati in mano potevano fare li
meno luminosi visti cose che mi chiami
entro gesù nel monitor perfetto ragazzi
siamo a 6
cioè non siamo a 4 mancano sei devo l'ho
vista l'ho vista l'ho visto l'ho vista
dal cielo velato le altre logiche della
foresta e mezzo spegne tutto non si vede
l'ho vista ragazzo mi ha sorpreso è
incastrato questo di castrato veloce mai
zio mai zio che manca al 5 vice e la
metà
parlando di tempistica dovresti
aumentare leggermente ritmo perché sono
non ce la facciamo col tempo perché
scade prima però in teoria siamo sulla
strada giusta in teoria
[Applauso]
dove è ora di dover che morissero i
cugini di diarrea spruzzo dal naso ma
almeno a vertice nel senso fate qualcosa
che si capisce che sta in groppa tizia
disegno del cazzo è dai guarda quanto
spazio c'è trasfigurate che lo vedete lo
spazio c'è lo spazio perché non ci pazza
papa culo se ti dico che te ne devi
andare affanculo te ne devi andare
affanculo devi correre a [ __ ] avete
visto quanto spazio c'è la tratta di due
miglia di alberi e non ci passavo in
mezzo e grave
mangia meno dal mcdonald perché se sei
talmente largo che non passi da lì è
grave ma tanto proprio in cui questa
casa è un sentiero che continua poi
finisce così pensano rotto il cazzo
quelli che hanno fatto il sentiero hanno
messo le pietre ei ragazzi sono convinto
non solo di non riuscire a finirla ma
sono convinto di non riuscire ad
arrivare manco quando sono arrivato
prima abbiamo fatto tipo cinque o sei
io non ce la farò mai più a fare 56 ve
lo dico già ragazzi in teoria dovrei
seguire una linea perché mi chiede
troppo grosso sto posto semi perdono le
trovo mai più le pagine però se finisce
sentiero lo con m potrebbe essere anche
un problema che dite tuttavia corri però
importante che non puoi scavalcare la
recinzione zio wifi e o sei un
deficiente che questo che non passa in
mezzo agli alberi quanto mi dà fastidio
a guardarci passa l'albero in mezzo e
costruita in mezzo all'albero
è successo calmi cosa è successo
mettiamo tutto il microfono perfetto
grazie gioco del cazzo dai vai vai non
ti fermare per l'amor del cielo vada non
changes chi uno stato che se guardi la
tizia fatemi giocare con bonnie varia
non son riuscito a finirlo un'altra
volta fatemi parlare con lui
se minchia journal nervoso che ammazzare
qualcuno non ho idea
anche tu sei un figo della madonna ed io
avevo veramente 60 secondi per fini sta
merda ta1 ci provo e ragazzi non vi
prometto niente anzi sono sappiate già
che perdo però ci provo almeno faccio un
tentativo ho trovato uno solo mancano 15
secondi perfetto ragazzi sono brava sto
gioco sono contento anche se li trovo
senza il secondi va bene non segua per
me è una vittoria anche anche se
l'obiettivo fallito frega cazzi x me la
vittoria a trovarli anche col tempo
scaduto prima che non riuscirò non ce la
farò lo stesso ve lo dico già capitana
quanto casino vai cordi però checa bravo
bravo bravo bravo bravo sono fiero di te
sono fiorite perfetto mente prendi
questo sono due siamo a due a due
non so se vi rendete conto siamo a due
non è che ci distinguono gli oggetti che
almeno li vedi lampeggiare sono oggetti
normali potrebbe anche essere una sedia
poteva anche essere un foglio potrebbe
essere tua nonna ecco tipo questo questo
era tra insieme a tre ragazzi siamo a
tre sono contento ci sto mettendo tre
vite e mezzo ma va bene da finire e io
non so neanche
cazzo sono il rettilineo ce l'ho fatta
ci ha fatto vedere ma porca [ __ ]
hanno preso non ci credo mai vi rendete
conto di quanto ci sto mettendo e è
finito il tempo 3 ore fa che mi sarebbe
scaduto sei volte il tempo fatto
perfetto mai va eccolo siamo a quattro
ragazzi prendilo perfetto 4 antonio da
dove è uscito da dove nove anche poi era
un 5 gli oggetti non sei
mi chiamavano manco contare lega non gli
avevo comunque trovati tutti e cinque
mancava uno anche senza il tempo è
impossibile l'unica 3 perfetto carri
incredibile ma il lato così lontano
oddio cos'è sta roba bragato ed ora come
succede torri voi cosa sta succedendo
madonna non ci credo mai mi mancano due
porca [ __ ] come da due sono non ci
voglio credere
ma tanto che palle ma ballamy niente un
regalo mi molla e va beh sì cazzi
importante che riprendo 6 2 dai dai dai
dai dai dai corri corri corri
ecco ma che a 1
manca uno non morirò così stronzo
ditemi dove sta minkia dico secondo me
quello che non sono mai riuscito a
trovare perché c'è più uno che non sono
mai riuscito a trovare perché non ho mai
capito dove ma tu come mi sono salvato
no va bene gas storica st giocata da
invitalia pro prete invece vi prende
[ __ ] che cazzo dai niente ragazzi
ce l'ho provato in tutti i modi
possibili immaginabili della storia
impossibile invece ci cara figo
se non fosse che è troppo dispersivo e
figo e ha ricordato i vecchi tempi
quando giocava lander man è stato
veramente figo quindi ragazzi spero che
vi sia piaciuto un bel mi piace per
circa un bel [ __ ] dove veramente
io ti odio c'è la persona più odiosa che
sempre che tu possa essere considerato
una persona più odiosa di questa terra
ancora veramente non lo voglio più
vedere ovvio basta ma prima l'ultima
volta che gioca sta roba vera visione
sia piaciuto e cosa servisse video
postato su un commento è un mi piace
anche a pagina di facebook e cavani 93
distinzioni sono restii dischetto ci
rivediamo nel prossimo vino ragazzi